[Musique]
monsieur magoo quel âge avez vous je
suis né le 6 février 1881 alors
conséquent actuellement salle ou à me
faire 85 et demi et donc vous êtes né
vous avez toujours vécu dans le xviie
toujours vécu dans le dix septième mois
vous savez que batignolles comme j'ai
déjà dit c'était un petit village et il
y est resté village bien longtemps
lorsque ce qu'il habitait d'ailleurs été
en principe des sédentaires ainsi par
exemple rouge demeure au 147 rue
legendre nous allions chercher l'aide
dans une boutique et les vaches étaient
dans le fond de la ferme enfin si on
peut appeler ça une ferme sur une petite
ferme et vous appréciez les nouvelles
inventions au moins comme je suis
toujours dans le même logement que j'ai
été mobilisé en 14 dans le logement où
je suis
les pros bougé de là est la seule chose
qu'ils inconvénients maintenance et je
m'aperçois qu'il faut que je montre ma
bicyclette au cinquième il s'est fait un
peu haut personnellement voilà ce que je
peux vous dire maintenant
en fait chez moi où il y avait justement
cette ferme que je vous parle il vient
de se monter une maison qui fait à peu
près dix ou onze étages et j'avais bien
peur qu'à le mot gêne pour le soleil
parce que j'ai un gros avantage je suis
au soleil d'ailleurs la lumière j'ai
tout pour moi seulement ma femme se
plaignait que la cuisine était pour bien
confort non pas pourquoi vous n'avez pas
la passion la cuisine les présidents la
salle à manger et vous avez
l'électricité quand même on par goût par
nécessité aubin l'électricité je le sais
pas on n'avait pas je les peuples les
proches pour l avoir évidemment pis y'a
une colonne montante mes enfants je suis
peut-être assez vieux jeu je suis
toujours au garage où on va moi ça me
gêne pas savez quand je vais aller au
spectacle tout ça bien je me dérange
mon spectacle favori c'est la comédie
française parce que j'aime les
classiques
alors si je veux voir un match de rugby
je me dérange
dimanche j'avais aller voir la course
des nations je me dérange
alors je questionnais j'aurais pas le
temps de s'occuper d'autre chose
parce qu'une fois chez moi j'aime être
tranquille par exemple j'ai appris deux
professions j'ai été mal pied et était
en valeur j'ai malquier et je me suis
même installé dans le xviie j'étais
installé aux huit passages legendre
j'ai hésité pour rentrer à la radio à
levallois comme en valeur et le puis je
vais conserver le métier leur valeur
parce que dont les êtres dans l'est
lorsque pourrait dire dans ce qu'il
plaît beaucoup dans l'emballage c'est
jean ballet des objets d'art oui est-ce
qu'on a jetée dans les tableaux les
statuts ou sa psy m'a donné l'occasion
de donner l'occasion de fréquenter des
artistes ça me plaisait bien des
souvenirs de ces artistes qu'elle avait
vous cognez objets connus redan comment
était-il commencer comment était-il week
est la maîtresse rodage pour communier
en son nom je venais pour le monde et
surnage à ce moment là je veux dire quel
homme s'était rodin quel genre d'homme
où j'avais je veux pas vous dire ce
qu'elle genre il avait à mon avis non
non je ne veux pas le juger c'est un
artiste avec ses défauts d'accord ou
presque il était gentil ce qu'il était
agréable ce que c'était facile
ah oui savez c'était plutôt un homme
bourru
et justement je me trouvais ici nous
sommes dans la télévision chez un de ma
famille qui a travaillé dans la
télévision vit qu'il était à la radio
laboral valois c'est pour aller jusqu'au
moment sa femme c'est un professeur et
il y avait une de ses élèves qui étaient
venus dans le genre d'invitation comme
ça alors quand je lui ai dit que j'avais
parlé à roland ham a considéré comme un
art qu'on a je me disais moi même ma
pauvre jeune fille qui situe si tu
connais c'est l'homme alors quelles sont
vos distraction favorite quoi vous fait
beaucoup de sport à wii sports jonage
fait de la bicyclette
et puis je me suis mis les classiques là
avec ça ça m'occupe bien fait de la
bicyclette tous les jours on l'a
longtemps olala ça chez vous arrêter ou
commence l'excès
[Musique]